Hocke
Moin, Zendrix, POG Subscription, geht gut los. Daily Scrum noch mal evaded.
Was macht eigentlich der Löwe in Berlin? Fällt mir gerade ein.
Mal kurz News gucken.
Bevor das Stream endet. Löwe in Berlin, was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich rausgekommen?
Löwin in Berlin, die Suche geht weiter. Gibt es denn irgendwas?
Kein einziger Hinweis auf Löwin. Entwarnung. Ja wie, Entwarnung?
Man hat ihn nicht gefunden, Entwarnung. Geil. Moment, Video soll ein Wildschwein statt einer Löwin sein, okay, okay.
Löwe in Berlin, Polizei vermutet Wildschwein.
Du warst nur ne Wildsau. Na gut.
Ich habe das gar nicht weiter verfolgt. Ich habe das nur gestern in den News gelesen. Hat mir so gesagt, alter Berliner, was auch sonst.
So Dinger passieren immer nur in Berlin.
Chizipro, Dankeschön für den Sub. Und Chris, POG Subscription. Oh, Dankeschön. Guck mal da, Scamtrain ist an Start. Kann Besus wieder ins Weltall.
Der will unbedingt ins Weltall wieder, glaube ich.
Habe ich euch schon die Story erzählt von...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Ist ja Boomer-Hirn. Es kann sein, dass es manchmal ein bisschen hängt. Habe ich euch die Story erzählt,
wo ich, als ich vor zwei Wochen so eine Einführungsveranstaltung auf der Arbeit hatte.
Und egal, ich erzähle es einfach noch mal. Also,
wir hatten so eine Einführungsveranstaltung. Ich bin jetzt zwar schon dreieinhalb Monate da, aber das ist,
da mahlen die Mühlen ein bisschen langsamer. Da hat man auch dreieinhalb Monate nach dem Angefangenen eine Einführungsveranstaltung. Zumindest,
ich sitze in der Einführungsveranstaltung, weil er war leider vor Ort. Ja, sitze ich da, gucke so am Tisch rum,
und denke mir so, also der Typ da drüben, der kommt dir eh schon wie bekannt vor.
Und wie das halt so geht bei Einführungsveranstaltungen, da macht man am Anfang so eine Vorstellungsrunde.
Da komme ich halt dran. Ja, hallo, ich bin der Max. Ich war vorher da und da. Und da kommt mein Kollege, den ich mitgebracht habe von der
Arbeit.
Hallo, ich bin der und der und komme vorher auch von da und da. Und auf einmal kommt der andere Typ gegenüber, der mir so schräg
gegenüber am Tisch sitzt, auch dran und meint, ja, ich bin hier der, der sowieso und ich war vorher auch da und da.
Moment.
Daher kenne ich dich.
Du warst bei dem gleichen Laden, wie ich vorher.
Mit dem hatte ich aber nicht so viel zu tun. Ich habe den bloß auf dem Gang ein paar mal gesehen.
Aber wisst ihr, daher kam der mir bekannt vor. Der ist einfach auch
quasi zum gleichen Zeitpunkt,
fast, also fast, fast zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Der war, der war erst ab 1. Juni da, quasi.
Ein paar Tage nur. Der ist quasi von der gleichen Firma dahin gewechselt, wie ich. Daher kam der mir bekannt vor.
Daily Scrum. Ja, Leute, gleich geht's los. Wer schreibt Protokoll heute? Moin Patrick.
Aber danke schön für den Sub, AeroChild.
Wer muss heute Protokoll schreiben? Wobei, eigentlich sind wir agil und da werden ja keine Protokolle geschrieben.
Wir werden ein bisschen Kanban-Board verschieben.
Wobei, es gab schon so viele Prime-Subs. Vielleicht fällt es Daily Scrum heute auch aus.
Sveld haben wir doch letztens erst gemacht. Das ist doch noch gar nicht so lange her.
Guck, hier. Archiv.
Sveld.
Ist erst knapp einen Monat her.
Sogar fast vier Stunden ging das Schreiben.
Pog.
Bewiesenermaßen nicht drei Monate her.
Hier ist es ein Jahr her.
Ja, aber wir können demnächst wieder was bauen.
Mir macht das Bock.
Was, das letzte Mal vor einem Jahr? Nee, vor einem Monat, Chill, oder?
LotharNox. Moin.
Ja, und da war ich echt überrascht, dass da auf einmal jemand gegenüber sitzt, den ich schon kenne.
Was machen eigentlich? Ach so, davor ein Jahr. Nee, davor fünf Monate.
Guck, ein Monat her, fünf Monate her und dann war es schon wieder ein Jahr her.
Aber wie gesagt, mir macht das Bock. Ich brauche aber irgendeine Geschichte. Also wenn du eine gute Idee hast, was wir bauen können,
dann schieß los, weil ich habe...
Jetzt war ich abgelenkt gerade hier auf dem anderen Monitor.
Ja, aber ich habe schon Bock drauf.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Frontend-Framework. Aber halt nur, wenn man eine gute Sache hat, die man bauen kann, sonst sackt es auch einfach.
Ich wollte mal kurz gucken, was machen denn die aktuellen Raspberry...
GPT-6 in Javascript, sehr gute Idee.
Und als nächstes bauen wir Postgres nach in Javascript, würde ich sagen. Moment,
bevor ich das jetzt sage, es gibt doch bestimmt schon irgendjemand, der eine SQL-Datenbank aufbauen möchte.
Es gibt doch bestimmt schon irgendjemand, der eine SQL-Datenbank gebaut hat.
Ja, okay, fast, fast.
Javascript Library to run as you like on the web.
So klar.
M-Scripten haben wir auch schon benutzt.
Mal was mit WebAssembly gemacht. Wir haben, glaube ich, den advancesten Shit, den es je auf Twitch zu sehen gab, in WebAssembly gemacht.
Und eines der advance- WebAs, wir suchen mal nach WebAs.
Ja, guckt es euch an.
Fünf Stunden, sechs Stunden.
Wir haben FF, guck mal, hier, wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut mit WebAssembly.
C++,
FFmpeg
und das Ganze dann in irgendein
Canvas, nee, in einen WebGL-Kontext gerendert.
Das war richtig nice. Den Code gibt es nicht online, den gibt es nur bei mir irgendwo lokal, den habe ich nie hochgeladen zu GitHub.
Aber das war extrem nice. Da konnte man beispielsweise Formate abspielen im Browser,
die der Browser gar nicht unterstützt. Du konntest zum Beispiel alte, so MPEG-2-TS-Sachen abspielen, hier so
20-Sekunden-Parl-Video
abspielen im Browser, obwohl Browser eigentlich den Codec gar nicht können.
Das war richtig, richtig nice und wir haben das, also da gibt es zwar Beispiele für ins Internet,
aber, also da gibt es Beispiele im Internet für, wie das geht, aber wir haben das viel besser gemacht. Wir haben das mit einem
Background-Worker-Thread gemacht, der das Video decodet, das Frontend hat in den WebGL-Canvas das Zeug rein gerendert
und
und genau und und das ist das, was alle Beispiele nicht können, die man online dazu findet, zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Wir haben das Video gestreamt. Wir haben das Video, guck hier, wir haben das Video gestreamt. Wir haben das Video nicht runtergeladen und dann abgespielt,
was ja nicht geht bei 5GB-Video, sondern wir haben das Video gestreamt. Wir haben das so angefangen runterzuladen, dann häppchenweise in FFMPEG gepumpt
und das decoded und dann gerendert in WebGL-Kontext. Richtig, richtig advanceder Shit war das, ja.
Also sowas hat auf Twitch garantiert noch niemand anderes gemacht und es gibt auch so gut wie keine Beispiele weltweit dafür, wie das geht.
Also das war schon ein nicer Stream, ja.
Bei Kleinzeit-Datenbank-Zugriff in Javascript auch so eine gute Idee ist. Ja, Moment, nee, nee, nee, es geht nicht um Kleinzeit-DB-Zugriff,
sondern, das kann man falsch verstehen, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich das dank der ganzen Prime-HiIQ-Prime-Subs richtig verstanden habe
und zwar, das ist nicht Kleinzeit-Zugriff auf eine Backend-Datenbank mit Javascript, das ist SQLite im Browser.
Das schreiben die ja auch hier.
Guck, SQLJS uses Emscripten to compile SQLite to WebAssembly.
Also die bauen SQLite für WebAssembly, das läuft vollständig im Browser.
Das hat nichts mit Backend oder sonst was zu tun.
Die Sache ist halt die, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was man genau mit SQLite im Browser machen möchte.
Ich meine, du kannst coole Features von SQLite benutzen, wie beispielsweise die Fulltext-Suche und sowas.
Vielleicht nicht verkehrt, aber Persistenz unter der Haube muss das Ganze eh irgendwie Local Storage machen.
Und Local Storage, Leute, weiß jemand aus dem Kopf, wie groß Local Storage standardmäßig sein darf?
50 MB pro Seite oder sowas?
Das ist nicht viel, das ist echt nicht viel.
Kurz, dick leiser machen noch.
Ja, außerdem gibt es ja noch sowas wie Index-DB, wenn man eine Datenbank im Browser braucht.
Also so hundertprozentig den Einsatzzweck davon verstehe ich nicht, aber das Ding hat 11.000 oder aufgerundet 12.000 Sterne.
Das muss schon einen Anwendungszweck haben, sonst hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht so eine Beliebtheit.
Ich wollte gerade mal was anderes gucken und wie sind denn die aktuellen Raspberry Pi Preise?
Ich glaube, das habe ich letztens schon mal geguckt, aber ich habe es mir nicht gemerkt.
Raspberry Pi 4 Modelle.
Nehmen wir mal den, der sich preis-leistungsmäßig eigentlich so am besten lohnt.
Warum gibt es 4 GB RAM?
Das ist doch genau das gleiche, oder?
Das hier und das hier.
Das muss ich nicht verstehen.
Ja, das ist schon immer noch ganz schön teuer.
Ich meine, es ist nicht mehr so total dämlich hängen geblieben.
130 Euro, aber es ist schon teuer.
Guck mal.
Hä?
58 Euro?
Wo 58 Euro?
Ach, 1 GB Modell sagt.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich teuer.
Ich weiß nicht, was der normale Preis war, als das gelauncht ist.
45 Euro oder sowas?
Ja, vor 10 Jahren gab es aber noch keinen Raspberry Pi 4 mit so viel RAM.
Vor 10 Jahren gab es, wenn wir Glück haben, den Raspberry Pi 2?
Oder ganz knapp 3.
Den Raspberry Pi 3 könnte es auch 2013 schon gegeben haben.
Guck mal mal.
Ja, ja.
Das stimmt, den gab es.
Und den gab es, glaube ich, nur mit maximal 2 GB RAM?
Oder sogar nur einem.
Ich weiß das aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr.
Einem nur, guckt mal.
Ja, kein Wunder, das RAM kostet ja auch Geld.
Es ist schon gerechtfertigt, dass die Dinger teurer sind.
Und ja, das hat irgendwie mal so 30 Euro gekostet.
By the way, übrigens, für die normalen Anwendungen, die man da so auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen will,
so kleinen Bastelkram,
vollkommen ausreichend hier 512 oder 1 GB.
Ich persönlich finde allerdings den mit 2 und 4 GB hier in dem Fall am interessantesten.
8 GB, ich bin bescheuert.
Ich habe mir 2, als mal lieferbar war, gekauft mit 8 GB.
Die liegen jetzt hier rum.
Aber preis-leistungsmäßig finde ich die am interessantesten.
Tatsächlich mit 2 oder 4 GB.
Mehr, also 8 GB RAM brauchst du auf dem Raspberry Pi eigentlich nicht.
Leute, für was, für was?
Also mal angenommen, ihr sagt, nein, wir brauchen Raspberry Pi mit 8 GB RAM.
Was will man mit 8 GB RAM in Raspberry Pi Sinnvolles machen?
Also was gäbe es jetzt da, wo ich sagen würde,
ja, dafür eignet sich ein Raspberry Pi richtig gut.
Und dafür braucht man 8 GB RAM.
Vielleicht, wenn man irgendwelche Sachen monitoren möchte mit Prometheus Grafana,
aber selbst das braucht für den Heimbereich nie und nimmer.
8 GB RAM?
Guck mal, nee, das, Leute, das ist ja eher nur Spielerei da drauf.
Also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, was wirklich 8 GB RAM brauchen würde.
ZFS auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Da brauchst du wahrscheinlich auch nicht 8 GB RAM.
Da schadet es dann mal so, wenn du Home Assistant drauflaufen hast
und hast es als Smart...
Die brauchen im Prinzip nicht viel.
Es kommt aber halt immer drauf an, was du für Plugins, für Addons, für Zusatzsachen installiert hast.
Wenn du zum Beispiel...
Ich zeige euch mal was, wo man viel RAM für braucht.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz, wo man viel RAM für braucht.
Ach Mist, die haben überhaupt keine...
Ich habe ja einen Home Assistant Addon programmiert und ich hatte einen Bug ganz am Anfang drin.
Normalerweise braucht mein Addon, keine Ahnung, 100 MB oder so.
70 bis 100 MB, wenn es gerade viele Daten zieht.
Also es hält sich in Grenzen.
Allerdings, ich hatte einen Bug in meinem Addon drin.
Das hat, glaube ich, am Anfang bis zu 4 GB RAM gebraucht.
Und...
Ist immer abgekackt.
Ja, genau, guck, hier habe ich es geschrieben.
Es ist runter von 700 MB RAM auf 114 MB RAM.
Ja, das war...
Also dafür braucht man...
Wenn du sowas laufen lassen willst, dafür braucht man viel RAM.
Und ich bin dahinter gekommen, weil die Leute das auf dem Raspberry Pi Club laufen hatten.
Und die hatten nicht viel RAM.
Und da ist das halt...
gecrashed.
Naja.
Also normalerweise brauchst du aber auch nicht so viel RAM.
Allerdings würde ich sagen, es gibt einen viel wichtigeren Faktor,
wenn du Smart Home gedöhnt auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen willst.
Und das ist eine ordentliche SSD.
Jetzt, ordentlich RAM ist auch okay, aber da würde ich sagen, reichen eigentlich,
je nachdem wie viel du machen willst, 2 oder sogar 4, also 4 GB oder vielleicht sogar 2.
Natürlich, Nummer sicher bist du mit 8.
Aber die SSD ist das Wichtige.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich muss unbedingt mal eine neue Version publishen,
wo ich ein paar grundlegende Sachen fixe, was für Probleme gibt.
Zum Beispiel, dass du mehr als ein Auto haben kannst.
Du kannst ja aktuell nur ein Auto haben.
Ne, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht.
Du kannst mehrere Autos vom gleichen Hersteller haben.
Du kannst aber nicht ein Auto von Fiat und ein Auto von...
Oder sagen wir mal die Amis, ja?
Also so ein Ami kann nicht...
Also die Amis können keinen Dodge Truck haben und einen Fiat.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil du immer nur einen Hersteller angeben kannst
und kannst das Addon auch nicht mehrfach installieren.
Das sind so grundlegende Dinge, die müsste ich echt mal fixen.
Und ich müsste auch noch ein paar Sachen mehr fixen, die nicht so gut durchdacht sind.
Beispielsweise auch, wie ich das ganze MQTT, die ganze MQTT-Integration mache, ist nicht so schlau.
Das müsste man mal aus den Sachen, die ich jetzt gelernt habe,
wie man so einen Addon gut baut, mal ordentlich gut bauen.
Aber ich bin gerade mega unmotiviert.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil es bei mir funktioniert.
Und ich habe es ja hauptsächlich für mich gebaut.
Guck mal, wenn man einen günstigen Raspberry Pi braucht...
Stream-Projekt. Wir haben vieles davon im Stream gebaut, ja?
Aber jetzt muss ich erstmal Off-Stream anfangen,
da ich so grob weiß, wie ich es bauen will.
Dann bauen wir auf jeden Fall im Stream weiter.
Schaut mal, wenn man es billig, wenn man es wirklich günstig haben will,
nimmt man ein Raspberry Pi Model...
Achso, das ist so einer.
Das ist der falsche Formfaktor.
Preisentwicklung öffnen.
Also guck mal, das war mal bei 31 Euro.
So viel hat das damals gekostet.
Wirst du UML-Diagramme dafür erstellen?
Genauso, wie ich Dokus schreiben werde.
Pflicht nervt. Ja, klar, Chat.
Leute, Daily Scrum.
Wer nimmt sich der Aufgabe an?
Wer nimmt das mit,
dass er die nächsten drei Wochen im Daily sagen kann,
bin ich dran?
Wer erstellt die UML-Diagramme?
Auf geht's.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das richtig funktioniert.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Anwendungsentwickler.
Ich konnte es noch nie richtig gut,
UML-Diagramme erstellen,
aber ich habe alles wieder vergessen.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass man irgendwie
plus for public Methoden
oder sowas machen soll.
Oder sowas.
UML-Diagramm.
Nee, mach gar keinen.
Das ist so ein Scheiß.
Ja, hier, guck.
So ein Schrott, Alter.
UML-Diagramm.
Macht das wirklich jemand noch?
Taze, danke schön für den Sub.
Raphael, hab kein was getrunken.
Aber ja, ich weiß,
es gibt Leute,
die machen wirklich
UML-Diagramme und Struktogramme.
Erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer
an das Video mit Herr N.
Was ich gemacht habe.
Herr N. spricht Klartext.
Und
da hat er irgendwo erzählt,
dass sie
irgendwelche Entwicklungen
für IBM-Hosts
nach Indien oder so outgesourced haben.
Und damit die Inder
was ordentliches programmieren,
machen sie Struktogramme.
Also, keine Ahnung, ob das
immer noch so ist, aber das war der erste
Einsatz, den ich jemals gehört habe
von Struktogrammen.
Manche machen das noch.
Ich hab's aber
sehr lang nicht gesehen.
Die letzten 10 Jahre bestimmt gar nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
UML-Diagramme finde ich halt Schrott.
Ja, so beispielsweise
so wie ist der
Kommunikationsfluss, ist ja gerade
umso mehr Microservice-mäßig man das Ganze
baut, nicht verkehrt. Oder was auch
was auch
beliebt sind, sind, kennt ihr
Ost-West-Diagramme?
Das hat nichts mit deutscher Geschichte
oder so zu tun.
Wer kennt Ost-West-Diagramme?
Ne, das meine ich gar nicht.
East, West
oder Flowchart
oder so, muss ich gucken.
Flowchart
Ne, das ist
alles nicht.
Das wird ganz gerne im Cloud-Umfeld
benutzt. Traffic.
East-West-Traffic.
Genau.
Das wird ganz gerne im Cloud-Umfeld benutzt.
Das ist quasi so, weil
der Traffic von links nach rechts geht.
Wenn ihr euch mal irgendein Diagramm von irgendeinem Service-Mesh
angeguckt habt, dann
steht da sowas drin.
Deswegen ist es East-West-Traffic.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist schon sinnvoll. Aber gerade
Struktogramme und
UML-Diagramme finde ich persönlich komplett
für'n Arsch. Braucht man...
Ich brauch's ja nicht.
Wollen wir uns heute mal den
Konferenz-Talk angucken?
Wir haben
ein bisschen Zeit.
Aber erstmal können wir noch ne Runde schwätzen.
Chat, hab ich irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst?
Wie sieht's denn aus? Es haben ein paar Leute im letzten
Stream geschrieben, sie haben...
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher,
entweder Bewerbung geschrieben oder
irgendwie die Woche Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ist einer von denen am Start heute?
Und möchte berichten, wie's gewesen ist?
Branchless
Programming.
Why if is slow?
Leute, ich seh's schon kommen, ja?
Wir müssen alle Ifs wegoptimieren.
Bald gibt's den Rust-Compiler,
der alle Ifs löscht.
Blazingly fast. Leute, es ist
überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich bin ja
schon seit langer Zeit am überlegen,
wir sollten einfach
nur noch
fehlerfreie Software
programmieren.
Und wie programmiert man am besten fehlerfreie Software?
Man erstellt einfach
eine Software, die
komplett jeden nur erdenklichen
Ablauf, den sie haben kann, schon enthält.
Und aus ganz vielen Ifs besteht.
Also egal, welchen Input man liefern kann,
es ist alles schon festgelegt, wie das läuft.
Das ist dann am Ende zwar größer
als alle
Teilchen im Universum zusammen an Festplatten,
aber es wäre fehlerfrei.
Der Carlson,
danke schön für 42 Monate Subscriptions.
Pog.
Huge.
An der Uni hab ich damals While gelernt.
Und?
Du hast gelernt, wie man Schleifen macht? Oder es gibt eine
Programmiersprache, die While heißt?
Also ich hab mit Ifschleife angefangen.
Noch jemand?
Ifschleifen-Enjoyer?
Es gibt eine Sprache, die heißt
While, besteht nur aus While.
Ifschleifen, das ist das
Beste, ne?
What the fuck?
Abartig aus.
Ein Ifschleifen ist das Beste.
Ah, ich hab irgendwas im Auge.
Würdet ihr
IT-Spezialisten behaupten,
dass ihr so geboren
wurdet?
Wurde?
Ähnlich
wie Schrauber.
Also ich geh nicht davon aus, dass Leute
wirklich
als Schrauber oder
als IT-Spezialist
geboren werden.
Ich denk mal, dass die Leute
gewisse Veranlagungen dafür haben,
ob sie sich für
technische
Sachen interessieren.
Aber ob das dann in Richtung
Schrauber oder in Richtung
IT geht oder sonst was,
hängt wahrscheinlich auch ganz entscheidend
zusammen, mit was die Leute
in Kontakt kommen.
Am Ende haben sie dann doch irgendwelche Präferenzen.
Aber wenn man
es so umgangssprachlich
beschreibt, ja, würde ich das schon sagen.
Ja, würde
ich schon sagen.
Ifschleifen, ja, die Seite kenne ich.
Das ist die Top-Seite.
Es gibt keine Ifschleifen, sondern nur
If-Abfragen. Ja, ist aber falsch.
Wir sind high IQ, wir wissen,
dass es Ifschleifen gibt. Genauso wie wir
HTML programmieren.
Glaub doch nicht
irgendwelchen random Seiten im Internet.
Glaub dem
5Head Twitch-Chat.
Wolltest
Archäologe werden?
Ja, warum nicht?
Ich glaube, es gibt wenig Jobs als Archäologe.
Wir hatten mal
einen Archäologe bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Und wisst ihr, was
der machen sollte?
Der sollte das machen, wo ich ja immer
richtig viel Bock drauf habe. Der sollte
Doku schreiben.
Und irgendjemand meinte dann
so ganz philosophisch,
ja, Dokumentation, Schreiben und
Archäologie haben sehr viel gemeinsam.
Und da hat er
dann einfach immer nur so blöd gelacht
und genickt. Du hast überhaupt, da hast du richtig
gemerkt, der hat überhaupt keinen Bock auf den Job gehabt.
Der wollte lieber Archäologen.
Archäologien machen.
Archäolo...
Was machen Archäologen?
Wenn ich Archäologe bin und gehe meiner Tätigkeit
als Archäologe nach, was mache ich dann?
Archäologe... Archäologen?
Archäologien?
Jetzt sag nicht Ausgrabung.
Nee.
Nein, nein, nein.
Altsch, Chat.
Nicht genug Prime Subs, nicht genug
5Head. Muss mal kurz meine
VM anschalten.
Also mit dem hatte ich mich
öfters auch mal in den Haaren.
Der war
sehr speziell, unser
Dokumentationsarchäologe.
An sich ist man mit dem wirklich gut klar gekommen,
aber wenn es so um Detailfragen ging,
waren das immer
ziemlich ausufernde Diskussionen.
Ja.
Mal kurz Update machen.
Zack. Yep.
Yep, Update.
Benutzt du jetzt auch Arch, by the way?
Ich will's hoffen.
Irgendwelche Non-Arch-User hier?
Ich hab leider
nur stellvertretend das Emote.
Irgendwelche
Non-Arch-Linux-User?
Eventuell sogar irgendwelche
Suse-User hier?
Any Suse-Enjoyers?
Okay.
Bin ich beruhigt.
Ganz so schlimm ist es dann doch nicht.
Also
es gibt ja Sachen, die würde ich verstehen.
Ja, wenn
einer zum Beispiel sagt, ja Max, ich bin
auf dem Server Debian-Enjoyer.
Würde ich sagen, okay, passt.
Oder meinetwegen auch noch Ubuntu.
Oder meinetwegen sogar Red Hat.
Oder CentOS. Wobei, naja, CentOS
in der Form. Das ist ja alles okay.
Das würde ich noch verstehen.
Aber wenn einer ernsthaft sagt, er ist Suse-Enjoyer
und dann auch noch auf dem Desktop.
Oder noch schlimmer.
Auf dem Server ist ja noch schlimmer.
Kann ich nicht verstehen.
Ja, optimale Distro.
Aber wenn
einer wirklich Suse freiwillig verwendet,
das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Also den einzigen Kontakt, den ich die letzten Jahre
über mit Suse hatte, war
für eine
Linux-VM auf der alten Arbeit
haben wir
Suse installiert,
weil für die Telefonanlage
ich glaube das war irgend so eine Siemens-Telefonanlage
vielleicht kennt
jemand von euch sowas.
Die hatten ihre Control-Software
nur so ported unter Suse.
Suse will jetzt RedHat
klonen.
Ja, sollen sie mal machen. Es fehlt noch ein ordentlicher RedHat-Klon.
Dann taugt das ja vielleicht was.
Es gibt ja keine gescheiten RedHat-Klons
mehr so mit richtig viel dahinter.
Es gibt jetzt noch
Alma und wie heißt das andere?
Wie heißt das andere? Black? Ne.
Irgendwas mit Black.
Das neue CentOS.
Alma, Linux. Okay. CentOS.
Ne, nicht Black. Rocky.
Wie komm ich? Vielleicht komm ich
wegen BlackRock da drauf. Ja, das kann sein.
Stonks.
Ähm, genau.
Das ist ja
das neue CentOS. Wenn Suse das
nachbauen würde, ganz ehrlich,
finde ich gar nicht verkehrt.
Suse hat ein bisschen Manpower und Kohle
dahinter. Können die durchaus
machen. Und ich hoffe,
sie knicken halt nicht instant ein,
wenn RedHat sie verklagt.
Streng genommen kann RedHat sie nicht verklagen,
aber RedHat macht ganz komische Dinger.
RedHat macht auch, es gibt keine
Sourcen mehr demnächst
und solche Geschichten.
Dann werden die erstmal wieder verklagt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, was mit RedHat los ist.
Na gut, doch. Ich weiß, was mit RedHat
los ist. RedHat wurde gekauft von
von IBM.
Da weißt du, was los ist.
Es ist ja so ziemlich alles Schrott
von IBM, was es gibt.
Das heißt, RedHat wird jetzt auch zunehmend immer weiter
Schrott. Ich meine, es ist einfach
alles zu Schrott geworden in den letzten
Jahren von IBM.
Okay, es gibt auch viele Sachen, die waren Schrott.
Kennt noch irgendjemand
Lotus Notes?
Wer sich mal erfreuen will an einem top
aktuellen E-Mail-Client.
Excellent.
So sah das früher aus.
Ja, so sah das aus.
Zwischenzeitlich
sah es auch mal ein bisschen moderner aus.
Also die letzte Notes-Version, die ich kenne,
die sah ungefähr so aus.
Aber halt auch
kompletter Shit, man.
Same time.
Same time war der Messenger,
war das Teams von Notes.
Wo liegt das Problem? Einfach zurückgraufen?
Wahrscheinlich daran, dass sie
nicht so viel Geld haben und es nicht machen wollen.
Ja, so. So sah das in Notes
immer aus.
Ja, diese hässlichen
Kacheln, Alter. Aber da sieht man auch,
dass IBM es dort nicht geschafft hat,
irgendwie konkurrenzfähig zu bleiben.
Lotus Notes, alle die Lotus Notes
hatten und da viel mitgemacht haben,
die phasen das out, haben es
auch abgeschafft oder sind
gerade am abschaffen.
Weil sie das
einfach jahrelang nur noch verwaltet haben
und nichts Sinnvolles dabei gekommen ist.
Und mittlerweile gehört es ja auch, glaube ich,
nicht mehr zu IBM.
Mittlerweile gehört es zu HCL,
wer auch immer HCL ist.
Immer noch Nummer 1
bei Dragstool? Ja, garantiert.
Letztens erst geguckt.
Ja, Notes, auf dem ersten Platz
war, also abgeschlagen,
weit oder mit weitem Vorsprung
auf dem ersten Platz.
Die Seite sieht übrigens nicht nur aus wie von 1995,
die ist auch von 1995.
Helpline kann ich auch komplett
verstehen. Helpline ist das
mieseste, nervigste
Ticketsystem, was ich je
benutzen musste. Teams,
verständlich, benutzen so viele, kein Wunder,
lassen ein paar voten. SAP,
keine Ahnung, hat es aber wahrscheinlich verdient.
DB2 hat es auch verdient. Project hat es auch verdient.
Outlook hat es auch verdient.
Ich mag Outlook nicht, auch wenn ganz viele Leute
auf Outlook schwören. NetBeans.
Moment.
Nee, das verwechsel ich
gerade mit IntelliJ. Von wem
kam NetBeans nochmal?
Apache, okay. Aber nicht von
Anfang an. Nun ja.
Wechselst du das mit CodeBlocks?
Nee, mach ich nicht. Das ist eine Java-Idee,
NetBeans. Du hast gerade mit IntelliJ
verwechselt, aber das sind andere Hersteller.
Du kennst nicht
U... Was für ein Ding?
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, wie man das aussprechen soll.
USU
Valumation
Was ist das? Okay, da muss ich jetzt
nachgucken. Schreibt mal
in die Kommentare.
Valumation
Öh!
Das sieht aus, als stehen da irgendwelche BWL
Stonks-Leute drauf, die es aber dann
selbst nicht benutzen. Öh!
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das...
Was ist das überhaupt?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das sein soll,
um ehrlich zu sein.
USU
Klingt wie so hochprozentiges Zeug zum
Saufen.
Valumation
Guck mal, das findet man bei denen auf denen ihrer Seite gar nicht.
Wie gesagt,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, aber es sieht
ultra-büsse-stonks-mäßig aus.
Leute, ich zeige euch jetzt mal
auch eine Software, die ich komplett
gelernt habe,
zu hassen.
Und zwar
hat jemand schon mal die Ehre gehabt, mit
Sabio-Wiki
zu arbeiten.
Ich glaub, Sabio hieß das Ding.
Sabio
Knowledge Management
Die
einfachste Wissensmanagement-Lösung
der Welt.
Sieht schon mal sehr einfach aus, auf den ersten Blick, ne?
Aber, ja, ja!
Das, oh Gott, Alter!
Das war das Grüne hier, ja.
Ach, du Scheiße!
Ja, ja, ja, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Nice.
So schlimm!
Ey, das war...
Das war ein Wiki,
in dem du nichts gefunden hast. Also, die elementarste
Sache einer Knowledge Base,
Sachen zu finden,
ging nicht.
Das war richtiger Schrott. Das war das schlimmste
Wiki, mit dem ich je arbeiten musste.
Ja, guck mal!
Genau, das hatte auch so einen abartigen
WYSIWYG-Editor. Ich hab's...
Haha, das weiß ich noch! Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Da hatten wir irgend so einen
komischen Verkäufer von denen da.
Ja, ich erinnere mich noch.
Und da haben die gesagt, ja, hier,
unser neues Webinterface.
Das Webinterface lief damals,
das seht ihr euch fest, das hat damals noch Flash
gebraucht.
Und da haben die uns das
gezeigt, die neue Version mit HTML5
und alles ist jetzt toll.
Und dann haben sie diesen WYSIWYG-
Editor gezeigt. Und da hab ich den Typ
damals gefragt, also diesen...
Wie nennt man das? Pre-Sales?
Oder diesen Sales-Typ.
Hab ich ihn gefragt, ob das Markdown unterstützt.
Und da hat er gesagt, was, Markdown?
Der wusste überhaupt nicht, was ich von ihm wollte.
Für den gab es so WYSIWYG-
Editor.
Da hab ich ihm versucht, das Ganze zu erklären.
Ja, MD,
Markdown-Format, dass man beispielsweise mit
ne Raute,
ne fette Überschrift formatiert.
Er sagt, ne, also Überschriften fett machen kann man hier
oben mit dem Button.
Also, guck mal, wenn ein
Wiki-Sales-Typ nicht weiß,
was Markdown ist, dann weißt du schon,
dass die Software einfach nur
abgrundtief sacken muss.
Damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Mit SAP bin ich bisher verschont geblieben
und hab ich auch nicht vor, mich damit zu
beschäftigen.
Storys von den Daily Scrums?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das hast du falsch verstanden.
Es gibt heute keine Storys von
Daily Scrums?
Wir machen heute Daily Scrum.
21 Uhr geht's los.
Bereitet euch schon mal vor.
Stand-Up, Chat, Daily Stand-Up.
Und wehe, ihr standet
nicht hier jetzt vor dem Monitor.
Gibt's direkt Report an
Chef.
Abmahnung ist raus.
Kanban-Board, ja.
Ich sehe schon, du kennst dich
gut mit der Thematik aus. Nimmst du das Thema
mal mit und präsentierst
uns dann morgen deine
Ideen dazu? Was ist denn
ein gutes Wiki? Wir gehen jetzt MediaWiki
auf wiki.js. Doku-Wiki
mag ich ganz gut. Äh, mag ich ganz gern.
Find ich ganz gut.
Doku-Wiki kann leider keinen Markdown,
nur mit Plugins. Aber wenn man einfach ein Wiki
haben will, find ich persönlich
Doku-Wiki nice, weil Doku-Wiki
alles im Klartext speichert.
Ich glaube,
die Datenbank brauchst du dann nur für History und User.
14 Tage.
14 Tage
Sprint. Wir sehen uns dann wieder.
4.
4. 8.
Schon mal eine Abmahnung kassiert.
Wie läuft das ab? Ich frag von woher du bekommst das?
Per Post. Aber ich weiß es.
Keine Ahnung. Ich hab noch nie eine Abmahnung
bekommen.
Relativ sicher bekommst du das per Post,
weil generell solche Sachen
werden... Bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob Abnahmen
... Ich glaube, Abmahnungen
müssen sogar auch schriftlich gemacht werden.
Da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher. Es gibt
ein paar Sachen, sowas wie Zeugnisse und
Kündigungen. Das muss schriftlich gemacht werden.
Also,
mündlich ausgesprochene Kündigungen könnt ihr euch auch
merken. Nicht rechts hier
beratungsmäßig, aber bin ich mir relativ
sicher. Mündlich ausgesprochene Kündigungen
könnt ihr komplett ignorieren.
Bookstack mag ich nicht, weil in Bookstack
kannst du schlecht automatisch was bearbeiten,
über die API, beziehungsweise
der große Vorteil von
Doku-Wiki ist halt, du kannst sogar mit einem
Bash-Skript an die Seiten ran. Vielleicht hat
Bookstack mittlerweile eine gescheite API.
Damals früher hat es das nicht gehabt.
Und ansonsten, ehrlich
gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, man braucht
heute eigentlich gar kein Wiki mehr,
wenn man jetzt nicht einen
Riesenaufwand hat und ganz viel
indizieren muss für Volltextsuche
und alles mögliche. Wenn man nur ein paar Themen,
ein paar Seiten hat, aber man hat
ein GitHub-Repo oder ein
GitLab oder was auch immer am Start,
dann kann man das ja einfach da drinnen
machen. Die haben ja mittlerweile auch Wiki-Komponenten
und sind mit Markdown auch schon relativ
gut. Und ansonsten, wenn man die Kohle
hat, kann man selbstverständlich auch so Sachen wie
Confluence benutzen.
Was ich gar nicht so schlecht
finde. Viele hassen Confluence ja komplett,
aber ich muss sagen, ich
finde Confluence gar nicht so übel. Leider
hat Confluence auch keinen Native-Markdown-Support,
sondern ihr komisches eigenes,
was ich immer nicht verstehe.
Ich finde Confluence
ganz okay.
Ja, für
so Wiki. Die Suche
ist halt scheiße, aber ich kenne eigentlich kaum
Wikis, wo die Suche nicht kacke ist.
Bei DokuWiki
ist die Suche nicht kacke, weil du kannst in den Ordner
gehen per SSH und einfach greppen.
Beste Suche.
Kennst du
Dokusaurus? Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Der hat aber schon mal
einen mega Namen, das Ding.
Facebook? Oder
meinst du wirklich Dokusaurus?
Confluence? Ja, Confluence
ist langsam. Das stimmt.
Dokusaurus
von Facebook.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Ist das der Dokusaurus?
Dokusaurus.
Und wie editiere ich das jetzt?
Gar nicht hier drin, oder?
Das check ich in irgendeinem Git-Repo ein
und das rendert mir das dann raus.
Verstehe ich das richtig?
Das ist also kein Wiki mit wir editieren das online,
sondern das ist eher ein
wir rendern aus einem Markdown-Repo
eine ordentliche Doku, so in der Richtung,
oder? Verstehe ich das richtig?
Ja.
Ja, nicht übel.
Autos in SAP.
Also, in der Automobilbranche
ohne Auto was zu machen, hätte ich keine Schmerzen,
aber auf SAP hätte ich keinen Bock.
Wirklich null.
Ja.
Nach einer Minute sind wir aus der Puste
fertig gesprintet. Wir machen
Microsprints. Moment, Leute.
Ich hab das Passwort
das, das, das, ja.
Alter, wenn das noch keiner... Moment.
Microsprint.
Fuck!
Warum haben das schon
andere sich ausgedacht wieder?
Das, das wäre einfach so ein,
das hätte so ein geiles Passwort werden können.
Microsprints.
Das ist so richtig, das ist so richtig
vom Wortklang
her, so ein bisschen wie Hyperscaler.
Oder
oder Sachen in der Richtung, ja.
Microsprints.
Gibt's schon. Natürlich gibt's das schon.
Sind schon andere Leute auf die Idee gekommen.
Nanosprint.
Wir machen's einfach noch kleiner.
Doch.
Manche sind sogar schon vor über 10 Jahren
auf die Idee gekommen,
Nanosprints zu benutzen.
What is a Microsprint?
Also eins muss man
den ganzen Leuten lassen, die sich mit so agiler
Methodik beschäftigen.
Denen gehen die Wörter immer nicht aus.
Also die haben immer,
jedes Jahr haben die irgendwelche neuen geilen Sachen.
Nenn mal eine
aufregende Enterprise-Software.
Oh, oh.
Ähm.
Ich mag Rider, aber Rider ist ja nur
eine Idee, und zwar ein ziemlich verbreitetes, keine
Enterprise-Software. Was ist eine
aufregende Enterprise-Software?
Ich glaube, sowas gibt's nicht.
Ich glaube, also
Chat, fällt euch was ein?
Also, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, vielleicht
Teams? Wenn man, wenn
man sich interessiert für Teams
Plugin-Entwicklung und sowas.
Lotus Notes.
Oh, ist der Chat zwischendurch abgekackt?
Ja, also Bitbucket mag ich persönlich
gar nicht, und ich bin froh, dass das immer
weniger benutzt wird. Aber Jira
finde ich somit das angenehmste Ticketsystem.
Weißt du, was denkt ihr,
Chat? Also, ich mag
Jira, oder Gyra,
wie die geilen Leute sagen, als Ticketsystem.
Confluence geht auch,
klar. Azure
DevOps. Ich dachte, der Trend geht ein bisschen hin
zu GitHub und GitHub Actions.
Und weg von Azure DevOps.
Leute, Chris,
wir haben auf der Arbeit auch
OneNote.
Und irgendwie
gibt's ein paar Leute,
die feiern das voll.
Ich versteh das nicht. Ich krieg auf der Arbeit
eh die Anfälle, wenn die mit Word
und irgendwelchen komischen Excel-Tabellen
und so teilweise um die Ecke kommen.
Ich habe Visual Studio Code,
Textfiles mit Markdown drin.
Fertig für mein Kram.
Gut ist...
Ja, ich versteh's auch nicht.
Gerane Flashbacks.
JavaScript Frameworks.
DocuSaurus.
Ja, anscheinend
hab ich mir das nicht gemerkt, dass ich schon vor
ungefähr
ein bisschen über einem halben Jahr schon mal was von
DocuSaurus gelesen hab.
Das ist auch so ziemlich das, was ich mitbekomme
von SAP. Dass es
ewig dauert und immer mehr kostet als geplant.
Ich glaub, das ist eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung.
Aber ehrlich, trifft das
nicht eigentlich für die meisten
Business-Enterprise-Sachen zu?
Dass es immer länger dauert und teurer wird als gedacht?
Nano-Sprints.
Mikro-Sprints.
Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Hempto-Sprints.
Leute, jetzt kommt die ultimative
Kurz-Sprint-Distanz.
Der Plank-Sprint.
Kleiner geht's nicht mehr.
Kürzer kannst du nicht sprinten.
Orthogonale Skalierung.
Wir müssen uns langsam
was anderes einfallen lassen.
Wir skalieren schon diagonal.
Es wird langsam
Zeit, fast schon für dreidimensional
zu skalieren.
Dann skaliert man vertikal,
horizontal und noch quasi
Z-Achse.
Du-Du-Du-Du-Du
Du-Du-Du-Du
Skalierung.
Top, top Idee.
Eine Stunde Planning,
eine Stunde Arbeiten,
alle zehn Minuten ein Stand-Up,
eine Stunde Retro.
Du wirst jetzt
wahrscheinlich das nicht ernst gemeint
haben, ja? Ist mir schon klar.
Aber ich möchte
trotzdem mal kurz was Ernstes dazu sagen.
Ich glaube sogar,
dass es irgendwelche Agile
Coaches und Leute gibt, die das
mega feiern würden.
Denkt ihr
nicht auch? Es gibt bestimmt Leute,
die würden das voll abfeiern.
Eine Stunde Plan, eine Stunde Arbeiten
und das unterbrochen, zehn Minuten
Stand-Up und eine Stunde Retro.
Und das heißt, du machst dieses ganze Ding hier
zweimal am Tag. Und wenn du Retro
gemacht hast, machst du wieder Planning.
Ich glaube, es gibt Leute, die würden das richtig feiern
und das dann auch noch auf Konferenzen
produzieren,
auf Konferenzen präsentieren
mit noch nie dagewesener Produktivität.
Musste in der Schule
eine Präsentation über Agiles
Project Management machen.
Habe 30 Minuten gebraucht, um alles von
Chat-GPT und Libris beschreiben zu können.
Hat es der Lehrer nicht gemerkt?
Ich glaube, du erzählst uns
nur die halbe Wahrheit.
Ich glaube, du hast uns jetzt mit Chat-GPT generiert,
aber du hast es bestimmt noch angepasst danach.
Was ist auf Reddit los?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was ist denn auf Reddit los?
Streiken sie wieder?
Kennst du I fucking hate Jira?
Jira?
Nö, kenne ich nicht, aber ich könnte
da auch ein bisschen drüber upranden,
was das Problem ist. Okay, lass mal gucken.
I fucking hate Jira.
Warum auf den Dinosaurier?
Okay.
Man kann es immer übertreiben,
aber prinzipiell ist Jira als Ticketsystem
nicht verkehrt. Wenn die Leute
dann da versuchen, das zu
großen
Bestien auszubauen, das ist ja
denen ihr Problem und nicht wirklich
das Problem von Jira.
Ne, habe ich nicht. Was ist denn da so Spannendes?
Ich habe gerade reingeguckt auf dem zweiten Browser,
zweiten Bildschirm, sieht eigentlich doch aus wie immer.
Oder nicht?
Sieht das irgendwie anders aus?
Ich habe das gerade ausgeklappt
und
ich sehe irgendwelche Weeb-Sachen.
Keine Ahnung.
Richtig. Und am besten
ist, wenn es auch noch komplett
fehlerfrei funktioniert, dann braucht man
weder Doku, noch Comments, noch Tests.
Beste Kombinator. Was man da für eine Zeit spart.
Das ist
keine schlechte Idee, aber es gibt
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr viele, die den Gag sogar
verstehen würden.
Doch, Daily, er hat seit sieben Minuten angefangen.
Ich habe ja gesagt, um 21 Uhr geht es los.
Chat, ich hoffe, ihr seid auch alle
am Stehen, ja? Nicht sitzen.
Daily Stand-Up.
Gucken wir uns doch mal durch, was heute schon
geschafft wurde. Beziehungsweise,
Chat, habt ihr irgendwelche Blocker oder Probleme?
Was habt ihr vor, heute zu machen?
Leicht angepasst. Ja, das dachte ich mir, dass du es
leicht angepasst hast, weil direkt von
Chat-GPT sagt halt.
Doch, und ich habe gerade drauf geguckt
und es sieht eigentlich
nicht viel anders aus als sonst.
Was ist dein Lieblings-KI-Tool abseits von
Chat-GPT? Copilot.
Und ansonsten,
was mega ist, sind
teilweise die
Build-Generator-AIs, wobei ich damit
recht wenig mache.
Ich warte immer noch drauf, dass Chat-GPT
Image-Input akzeptiert.
Oder geht das mittlerweile?
Bestimmt immer noch nicht, oder?
Geht bestimmt immer noch nicht.
Jetzt haben die schon
bei der Ankündigung gesagt,
die haben ja einen Trailer gemacht am Anfang.
Oh, schaut her, wie geil das neue Chat-GPT ist.
Das kann jetzt auch Images als Input.
Ja, nur das Problem ist halt, dass die Images nicht als Input
angenommen werden.
Und bis jetzt auch noch nicht
live geschaltet wurde.
Der Carlson hat subscribed. Sorry, falls ich es
übersehen habe. Danke für den Sub. 42 Monate.
Pog. Extremly Pogu.
Ich sehe bei mir alles im Zeitplan.
Die Helm-Charts sind fast fertig und ich werde heute
Abend ein Deployment auf den Death-Names-Beta...
Siehste? Vorbildlich.
Der Rache-Klaus.
Exzellent.
Ich würde sagen, du wirst unser neuer
Head of
Continuous Integration
und Delivery.
Gibt es eigentlich die agilen Broggers noch
auf GitHub?
Bester Gruppenname.
Ich mag Helm-Charts auch nicht,
aber Helm-Charts sind der Standard
schlechthin, wenn du Software bekommst
von einem Hersteller. Da kommst du nicht drum herum.
Für eigene Sachen kann man sich ja
andere Möglichkeiten
näher anschauen, aber man kommt
um Helm-Charts an sich und um
Pavelio-Files zu erstellen einfach nicht drumherum.
Neues Video von
Fireship. Lama.
Moment, AI
wird dümmer.
Ja, das habe ich heute auch, glaube ich, bei Heise oder so
gelesen, dass Chat-GPT
schlechter geworden ist im
Beantworten von mathematischen Fragen.
Schauen wir uns doch mal an,
was Fireship dazu sagt.
Job in der Altenpflege gekündigt.
Lohnt sich das?
Nee, nee, anscheinend hat sich das nicht gelohnt.
Und ich glaube
auch, dass es sich so allgemein gesagt
nicht lohnt.
Und dass die Arbeitsbedingungen scheiße sind,
die Bezahlung scheiße ist und der Druck viel zu
groß ist und das halt keiner machen will.
So, jetzt gucken wir
uns mal das aktuelle Video an von
Fireship. Was erzählt er uns denn
ob AI... Ich gucke ja
normalerweise keine AI-Videos, aber
Fireship gucke ich gerne, also
einfach, weil es zu viel Overload die letzten Monate über gab.
Auf Fireship gucke ich immer gerne,
der macht das auch meistens ganz lustig.
Und es ist kurz und knackig.
Ja, okay, also von vor zwei Monaten.
Ja, das ist aber auch daran,
weil die
zig Sicherungen eingebaut haben,
weil die Leute teilweise da schon
ja, vielleicht nicht so ganz
gesellschaftlich
kompatible Sachen gefragt haben.
Lauter?
Lama ist das von Facebook, gell?
Ja, das sagt...
Facebook ist doch auch nur so großzügig,
weil sie ein bisschen hintendran sind und
versuchen so das unter die Leute zu bringen.
Was keine schlechte Taktik ist,
ja,
aber mal gucken wie das aussieht,
sobald es ein bisschen mehr verbreitet ist.
Wenn du es selbst
hosten kannst und das nix verschickt,
dann kannst du das mit confidential Daten
benutzen, ja.
Ähm, Miko, das passiert doch jetzt teilweise schon.
Das passiert...
Es gibt doch jetzt schon Mods.
Ich hab letztens einen Skyrim-Mod gesehen,
der war komplett voiced,
allerdings mit
AI-Voice und solche Geschichten.
Also, gerade für Spieleentwickler
denke ich, bietet dieses Thema
enorm viele neue Möglichkeiten.
Von
Materialgenerierung,
Technologie,
von
Materialgenerierung,
Texturgenerierung,
ich meine Quest-Texte jetzt
vielleicht eher nicht, weil ich glaube,
ehrlich gesagt,
also wenn du Chat-GPT-Quest-Texte machst,
dann kannst du dir die Quest-Texte
eigentlich auch sparen und eine kurze Zusammenfassung
posten, ja.
Naja, aber vielleicht in Zukunft Quest-Texte,
aber zumindest Vertonung.
Vertonung
könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen für
Mods oder für kleine Games,
die halt
sagen wir mal umfangreichere Spiele haben,
sagen wir mal irgendwelche RPGs zum Beispiel,
die profitieren halt meistens enorm
von gesprochenen Dialogen,
von gesprochenen Quest-Texten.
Und auch wenn es jetzt nicht hundertprozentig perfekt
ist, da finde ich,
hat das gewissen Nährwert.
Und man kann ja schon ziemlich viel
AI-generiert machen
mit
Sprachgenerierung.
Das finde ich für die Zukunft echt nicht
verkehrt.
Ja, das ist eh das Erste, was es für Skyrim und Sachen
wieder geben wird.
Sollte es mal irgendwann das nächste
Elder Scrolls Game geben, was ja schon
seit acht Jahren oder so angekündigt ist,
dann ist sicherlich das wieder
eines der ersten Mods, die es gibt, ja.
Es ist doch bei 3D, äh, nicht bei 3D,
bei VR
das Gleiche. In welchem Bereich
hat sich VR durchgesetzt?
Es gibt eigentlich nur einen Bereich,
wo das so richtig Fuß gefasst hat,
auch mit vielen, äh, vielen
ist vielleicht übertrieben, aber mit Anbietern
und Content Creation
dafür und sonst was. Und das ist
die Leute, die sich mit VR-Brille
irgendwelche Porns angucken.
So ähnlich wie damals
bei Videokassetten und so was.
Oder DVDs
und alle möglichen Sachen. Oftmals
setzt sich das tatsächlich wegen Porn durch.
Und dann zum Schluss der LLAMA 2-Respons
war der am meisten verboten und gut geschrieben.
Aber je mehr man benutzt, desto weniger
ist es so kompliziert. Zum Beispiel beim Vergleich
mit Poetry ist es ziemlich klar, dass es
eine gewisse geheime Sauce bei OpenAI hat.
Die Poetry ist einfach viel poetischer.
Und bei Coding war LLAMA nicht so
nützlich, besonders mit mehr komplexen
Programmierungsbedingungen. Es ist aber nicht wirklich
eine faire Vergleichsaufgabe, weil GPT-4
beendet und bezahlt ist. Bei den eigentlichen
Benchmarks auf anderen Open-Source Modellen
ist LLAMA 2 wahrscheinlich die beste Option.
mit vielen technischen Details, wie das Modell funktioniert,
was viel nützlicher ist als die kryptischen Marketingbroschüren von OpenAI.
Wisst ihr, es wäre jetzt ein richtig geiler Plottwist,
wenn dieses Paper von Lama geschrieben worden wäre.
In dem Papier wird die Wörter Sicherheit 299 Mal erwähnt.
Eine der wichtigsten Arten, wie sie es sicherer machen,
ist mit Reinforcement-Learning von menschlicher Feedback,
wo echte Menschen die Ergebnisse der AI lobotomisieren,
damit sie schlechte Dinge nicht tun.
Was ein bisschen enttäuschend ist,
ist, dass ich gedacht hätte, dass wir jetzt alle in der Singularität sind.
Oder am wenigsten würde die AI alle übernehmen und alle zerstören.
Aber jetzt bin ich hier und mache Videos über Javascript.
Frameworks und Verkehr auf dem Chat-GPT-Site
sind letztes Jahr um 10% zurückgegangen.
Und ein weiteres Papier, das gerade kam,
spricht darüber, wie die Leistung von Chat-GPT über Zeit verändert wird.
Wenn es um Code-Generation geht,
fanden sie heraus, dass die Ergebnisse immer verbesserter werden
und weniger direkt erfolgsbereit sind.
Und das ist eine schlechte Sache,
weil ein guter Programmierer konkrete Codes schreibt, die sich kompilieren.
Fuck dich so ab,
dass, wenn es irgendwann kompiliert ist,
wahrscheinlich 500 Mal überdacht wurde
und dann auch das macht, was es soll.
Ja gut.
Ist ja auch verständlich.
Ich meine, was würdest du machen,
wenn du dein Haus verteidigen musst
und keine Atombombe hast?
Was machst du, wenn der Einbrecher eine Atombombe hat
und du hast keine, um dich damit zu verteidigen?
Dann hast du obviously gelitten.
Also ich finde das schon ein valides Argument,
dass man das braucht.
Okay, AI wird dümmer.
Also das war jetzt die Standard-Ami-Argumentation,
warum man Maschinengewehre daheim braucht.
Für WoW Classic gibt es mittlerweile
ein Gigabyte add-on, der Quest-Hacks
The Voice of a...
Okay.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Genau für sowas ist das mega nice.
Ich meine, du merkst das,
das kann ja nicht sein,
dass es so einfach ist,
Ich meine, du merkst das,
dass es kein professioneller Voice-Actor ist,
aber es hört sich schon sehr gut an.
Es hört sich halt ein bisschen monoton an,
aber es hört sich sehr gut an.
Ich meine, es könnte auch ein echter
Voice-Actor oder Sprecher sein,
der halt einfach nur gelangweilt sich anhört, aber...
Das ist wirklich gut, oder?
Also das ist wirklich nice.
Davoodoo
Ja, also das ist...
Gerade für solche Sachen
stelle ich es mir halt auch wirklich pock vor.
So AI-Voice-Generierung,
AI-Quest-Texte-Generierung,
naja,
da kann man es verstehen.
Also das ist wirklich nice.
Naja,
da kann man es wahrscheinlich auch sparen.
Das ist auch nur Low-End-Warhammer.
Naja,
in puncto MMO
war ja das Warhammer-MMO nicht so erfolgreich.
Wobei, es gibt tatsächlich einen Freeshot,
der ganz, ganz gut läuft.
Falls irgendjemand mal das Warhammer-MMO gespielt hat
und Bock drauf hat.
Also es gibt einen Freeshot,
der läuft ganz gut.
Der hat schon seit Jahren
immer so die gleichen Player-Zahlen und so.
Also ich spiele da nicht aktiv drauf.
Sag nur.
Weiß nur, dass es den gibt.
Ist das wirklich noch online?
Nee, das haben die doch abgestellt.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das haben die abgestellt.
Ja.
Das wurde abgestellt 2013.
Sagt sogar Wikipedia.
Chat?
Achso, das was ich gezeigt habe.
Ja, das weiß ich.
Deswegen hab ich's ja gezeigt.
Weiß, dass das online ist.
Gibt's ja seit einer Weile den Freeshot.
Also wer da Bock drauf hat.
Die scheinen auch recht stable zu sein
mit den Spieler-Zahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die irgendwie versuchen
eigenen Content dafür zu basteln oder nicht.
Spielst du noch Battlefield 2042?
Findest du den aktuellen Stand des Spiels?
Stimmt.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mit neuer Season aus?
Sollte da nicht demnächst...
Nee, New Dawn haben wir schon gespielt, oder?
Es ist so generic einfach nur das Game.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was wir davon schon gespielt haben
und was nicht.
Map.
Neue Map.
Ich glaub Season 6 haben wir noch nicht gespielt, oder?
Ende September, Anfang Oktober.
So lang?
Alter, die brauchen ja ewig, man.
Wie viel Spieler-Zahlen?
Steam-Charts.
Wie viel Spieler-Zahlen hat das aktuell?
Naja.
Ich mein, es ist spielbar.
Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5
haben wahrscheinlich immer noch mehr Spiele,
aber es ist spielbar.
Es war doch, glaub ich, sogar so,
dass die ursprünglich ein Warhammer-Game
machen wollten.
Aber es dann Probleme gab
und dann ist Warcraft draus entstanden.
Und später, und später dann Starcraft
und Zeug.
Ich mein, man sieht ja eindeutig,
dass Starcraft auch sehr große Anleihen
an Warhammer hat.
Also.
Ich mein,
kann auch beides sehr gut parallel existieren.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
Blizzard ist eh dead.
Da kommt nie wieder was Gescheites.
Also,
im klassischen Sinne,
das ist die Möglichkeit,
was Blizzard früher ausgezeichnet hat,
dass du Spiele hattest,
die ewig in Entwicklung waren,
aber wenn sie rausgekommen sind,
einfach besser,
als man sich's überhaupt vorstellen konnte
für dieses Game.
Und vor allem auch insofern innovativ,
dass es immer was ist,
wo man halt denkt,
okay, krass,
eigentlich ist es doch so naheliegend.
Warum ist da sonst noch keiner draufgekommen?
Blizzard is dead.
Ich mein, Blizzard schafft's zwar immer noch
ab und zu mal ein Gescheites.
Moin, Leute.
Heute wollte ich gar nicht anklingen.
Nee, die haben jetzt mit Diablo 4
seit Jahren mal wieder ein gutes Spiel rausgehauen.
Aber das ist ja auch nur
im Prinzip aufbauend auf dem,
was schon da war
und sich dann drumherum alles noch abgeschaut.
Zumal es jetzt ja auch schon anfängt,
ganz stark zu bröckeln
mit der aktuellen Season.
Und
also ich hab's mir nicht gekauft,
Diablo 4,
nachdem mich Diablo 3 ziemlich enttäuscht hat
und mich Blizzard auch die letzten Jahre
immer so abgefuckt hat.
Ich hab's nicht gekauft
und ich werd's wahrscheinlich auch nicht kaufen.
Wo ich richtig Bock drauf habe,
wäre endlich mal Path of Exile 2.
Ich weiß nicht, wie's da aussieht.
Ja, Overwatch wurde richtig in den Sand gesetzt.
Ich hab gewundert,
da sind ja auch die Leute alle
links und rechts abgehauen.
Haben die nicht gesagt,
dass sie das zur diesjährigen
Exile, ExileCon
vorstellen wollen?
Wann ist denn das?
Ach, das ist jetzt bald.
Das ist ja in der Woche.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt,
ob sie da wirklich was vorstellen.
Die haben, ich bilde mir ein,
die haben gesagt,
dass sie Path of Exile 2
jetzt endlich mal ein bisschen
detailliert vorstellen wollen.
Also da hab ich viel mehr Bock drauf
als auf Diablo 4,
ganz ehrlich.
Path of Exile 2
der wird Kreiselgrind Deluxe gemacht.
Als nächstes werd ich mir erstmal
Baldur's Gate 3 geben.
Kommt ja auch bald raus in zwei Wochen.
Es gibt halt eine Sache,
die mag ich jetzt schon
an Baldur's Gate 3 nicht
und das ist, dass es so eine
Party Size von 4 Spielern
äh, nee, 4 Characters hat.
Ich finde, 6er Party
ist das Beste, was es gibt
für so Games.
Aber ich geh davon aus,
dass es trotzdem ziemlich nice wird.
Es fühlt sich zwar vielleicht
eher an wie ein Divinity Game,
weniger nach einem Baldur's Gate,
aber solange ein gutes RPG rauskommt
ist mir das schon recht, ja.
Wayfinder
Game, nö, kenn ich nicht.
Sieht nach Weeb Game aus
in der Vorschau.
Ne, ist es nicht.
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Neues MMO?
Naja, neue MMOs
ich hab ja da immer
eine Zweifel.
Die großen MMO-Zeiten
sind leider vorbei.
Persönlich sind MMOs immer noch mein
Okay, ich kann nicht sagen
mein Lieblingsspiele-Genre,
das kann man so nicht sagen,
aber meine Lieblings
ähm,
ja meine Lieblingsspiel-Beschäftigung
aller Zeiten
so im Endeffekt
zu spielen. Ich fand MMOs immer richtig geil.
Ich spiel ja immer noch ab und zu.
Ich spiel jedes Jahr
ein paar Monate Darkfreeshot
und sowas noch.
Das letzte MMO, was ich
wirklich viel gespielt habe,
war
Final Fantasy
äh,
Leute, wer kann römische Nummern? Was ist das?
Zwölf? Ne, ach, keine Ahnung.
Ne. Vierzehn?
Vierzehn? Ist das Vierzehn?
Eins vor und dann Vierzehn?
Ja. Das war das letzte MMO,
wo ich wirklich richtig, wo ich
richtig viele Stunden reingesteckt habe.
Da habe ich mit Fabian noch gespielt
und da haben wir
aufgehört, dann
nach dem ersten Add-On,
weil wir mit dem ersten Add-On
komplett durch waren, also das war
zum Zeitpunkt, als gerade Heavens, Heavens
Heavensward
oder so hieß das, rausgekommen ist.
Das haben wir komplett durchgespielt,
Kreiselgrind gemacht. Wir haben irgendwie
in ein paar Monaten 800 Spielstunden
ja, ja
oder in nicht allzu langer Zeit 800 plus Spielstunden
da raufgelegt auf das Game
und dann waren wir am Ende
des Add-Ons und es gab halt einfach
nichts zu machen.
PvP in Final Fantasy 14 hat halt gesagt
und insofern haben wir
einfach aufgehört zu spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile
bessere Aktivitäten gibt, wie man da
24-7 Kreiselgrinden
verwalten kann. Ja klar.
Wie gesagt, wir haben zu dem Zeitpunkt
kurz bevor das erste Add-On
rausgekommen ist, angefangen.
Achso, du meinst vor.
Du meinst vor Realm Reborn.
Ne, da haben wir nicht gespielt.
Hast du den
Skandal mit
Throne and Liberty mitbekommen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
MMO. Ah, NC Soft
Keg Wade. Naja, da wundert mich nix.
Da wundert mich nix mehr.
Da weiß ich gleich schon, was ich zu erwarten hab,
wenn ich das lese. Kannst du
das hier mal durchspielen? Ich klick jetzt.
Also die Seite sieht nicht so aus.
Ach, das kenn ich. Das kenn ich.
Doch, das kenn ich. Das kenn ich.
Naja.
Das kenn ich. Kannst du die Seite mal durchspielen?
Da geht's da drum.
1, 2, 3, 5, 6.
Dass du nie ein richtiges Passwort
eingeben kannst. Your Password must contain
uppercase letter. Ah.
Special case character. Underscore.
Must add
up to 25.
Jetzt wird's langsam abgedreht.
Also ich mein,
wir können einfach sagen 25.
At least 5
characters. Kein Problem.
Ach, Moment. Must add up to 25.
Also kann
ich dann quasi sowas machen wie hier.
Ähm.
Wie macht man das am besten?
18 und irgendwie
20, 25.
Must include
a month of the year.
Äh, 07.
Das ist echt gut gemacht.
Also im Prinzip mach ich jetzt 0,
7, davor.
Moment, hab ich doch.
Oder muss ich einfach nur 7 machen?
Äh.
Ach sowas wie Februar muss ich da schreiben
oder was?
Okay, das ist nicht.
Was?
Roman numerals in your password
should multiply to 25.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Jetzt vorbei.
Was macht denn eigentlich BattleBit
SteamStats? Was haben die denn für
Spielerzahlen?
Ich hoffe, die halten es.
Ich würd's mir echt wünschen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist zu erwarten.
Hält die Spieler
aber besser als Battlefield
2042?
Warten wir mal, wie hoch's wieder
von Ende geht.
Letzten Wochenende waren ja recht hoch.
Ich würd's mir wünschen,
dass die die Spielerzahlen halten.
Also sagen wir mal so
50k plus vielleicht, auch wenn's utopisch ist.
Das wird's nicht schaffen.
Aber, mal gucken.
Es könnte auch sein, dass es komplett
explodiert, wenn sie jetzt
Content-as-fuck rausbringen und richtig
gute Neuerungen und alles.
Vielleicht wenn sie noch ein paar Leute einstellen.
Weiß ja nicht, was die vorhaben. Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf,
was sich entwickelt.
Ah ja, nice.
Mittlerweile verwende ich das übrigens nicht mehr.
Ich verwende mittlerweile das ganz normale Windows-Terminal.
Find ich, es gibt eigentlich keinen richtigen
Anwendungszweck mehr für CMDer.
Ich glaub, der einzige Vorteil war nur noch,
dass es ein paar mehr
Build-in-Bash-Kommandos gab.
Nee, war da glaub ich auch nicht.
Aber du kannst es unter Windows 10
genauso verwenden,
das Windows-Terminal.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass es unter Windows 11
vorinstalliert ist und unter Windows 10 musst du es nachinstallieren.
Aber geht sogar
über den Store,
falls du den Microsoft-Store benutzen möchtest.
Wer auch immer sowas will.
So, Chat-Gil.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Spannendes, was wir uns angucken können?
Job in der Altenpflege gekündigt.
Gehalt und Alltag als Saisonarbeiter
in den Bergen. Achso, ich dachte als Altenpfleger.
Prüfen sie ihr Internet.
Okay, Leute, ich predikte was.
Zwar ich predikte,
dass er am Anfang sagt, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Okay, das muss man nicht predikten, das macht er nie in einem Video.
Aber mal schauen.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Post-Champ, Post-Champ.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt.
Nur ganz kurz gezeigt, okay.
Aber fast, fast.
Prüfen sie ihr Internet.
Ne, das muss ich nicht prüfen.
Heute ist mein...
Es wurde vorhin wieder abgekackt.
Warum höre ich keine Musik an?
Heute ist Vodafone bei mir
wieder abgeschissen.
Ich musste meinen Router
neu starten, dass es funktioniert.
So schnell wird dein Fahrrad
zu Elektroschrott.
Yep.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das,
was ich letztens auch gezeigt habe.
Mit dem
niederländischen
E-Bike Hersteller.
Wo das Fahrrad
gekoppelt werden muss mit einer App.
Und damit die App funktioniert,
muss irgendein
Bluetooth Decryption Key vom Server
gezogen werden.
Und wenn der Hersteller pleite geht,
bzw. ich glaube, der ist mittlerweile pleite,
und die Server abgeschaltet werden,
dann funktioniert das Fahrrad nicht mehr richtig.
Du kannst dann beispielsweise die Helligkeit
vom Licht nicht mehr einstellen und sowas.
Es hat richtig hängen geblieben.
Hyper pipega.
So, haben wir nicht noch irgendwas, was wir uns jetzt mal
auf die Schnelle angucken können?
Was schönes, klotziges, knackiges.
Gucken wir uns am Sonntag an.
Wir können uns den Half-Life
Opposing Force Cryptless Speed Run
angucken. Ne.
Reicht die Zeit für nicht.
Warst du mal in der Schweiz, Max?
Ne. Und ich war auch
noch nie in einer Wüste.
Was will er?
Just, just code, man.
Okay.
Best advice I have for new programmers.
Gucken wir uns das an.
These coding projects
give you an unfair advi...
Das ist doch, das ist doch alles
Ultra-Chibait wieder, oder? Vom Titel.
Ich hab, ich hab Plays
vorhin gesehen auf Reddit. Ich hab nicht den großen
Unterschied erkannt. Oder hab ich...
Muss ich noch ein paar mal refreshen, oder so?
Okay. Was, was ist das beste
Advice für new programmers?
Also mein Advice kennt ihr ja.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, mit was ihr anfangen sollt,
dann mit nem Texteditor, nem Browser
und JavaScript. Aber okay.
Let's go.
Auf.
Jetzt, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich dachte,
da kommt jetzt was.
Jetzt hat er geschickt übergeleitet.
So, ah, bevor ich euch das beantworte,
nee, eigentlich ist die Frage nicht gut gestellt.
Und das erzähl ich euch warum.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Da kommt glaub ich nix Gescheites bei raus.
Chance, Chance vertan.
Denied.
Second Project. Okay.
Programmiere Einsteigerprojekte.
First Project.
Was macht der hier?
Ein File Explorer oder
sowas?
IoT-Sachen, okay.
Webseite.
Drittes Projekt.
Crypto-Shit
oder sowas?
Finance for...
Tic-Tac-Toe. What the fuck?
Fifth Project.
Keine Ahnung.
Das sind alles so ein bisschen Jibade-Videos.
Moment, das muss jetzt...
Sehr gute Idee.
Pog, Pog-Song.
Paper, please.
So. Das Game hat
den besten Soundtrack, auch wenn es nur 5 Stücke
oder so hat.
Es ist wieder aktiv.
Ach, das meinst du.
Ach so.
Deswegen wird heute
was von Places geschrieben, dass es wieder
da ist. Das hab ich gar nicht
mitbekommen, dass es so lange weg war.
Weil ich bin da so gut wie nie drauf
gewesen.
Warum nicht?
Unverständlich.
Dafür gibt's den
Spielchamp.
Versteh ich nicht.
Ich find das ganz normal, dass man
Tabs offen hat.
Man muss ja seinen RAM auch ein bisschen auslasten.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt RAM
und benutzt den nicht. Das war rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Einfach mehr Tabs aufmachen. Fertig.
Eats.
Easy.
2 Terabyte RAM.
64G reichen schon.
Aber 2 Terabyte RAM wär auch nice.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie unglaublich teuer
2 Terabyte RAM früher gewesen ist?
Als ich noch beim Provider
gearbeitet habe, also
oder so,
hatten wir tatsächlich IBM Plates
mit 2 Terabyte RAM.
Das Ding war
damals voll mit 64G Modulen
und das, also so ein
Plate hat wahrscheinlich damals
schon 80.000 Euro gekostet oder so.
Das war ultra teuer.
Und dann haben sie Felix und mich damit durch Frankfurt geschickt.
Wir sind dann mit 2
80.000 Euro
teuren Plates
unterm Arm durch Frankfurt gelaufen.
Zum Glück wusste in Frankfurt niemand, wie teuer
der Scheiß ist, den wir da unterm Arm haben.
Also
solche Dinger meine ich.
Ja, so Dinge hier
zum Reinschieben.
Also wir sind nicht mit so einem kompletten Ding, wir sind mit sowas
hier unterm Arm durch die Stadt
gelaufen. Genau mit sowas.
Aber halt in der Variante voll
bestückt mit 64G Modulen.
Da war dann hier alles voll.
Ganz ehrlich, 2 Terabyte RAM
sehen weniger aus, als es eigentlich
den Anschein hat, wenn man mal sowas
voll bestücktes sieht.
Vielleicht waren es auch 128G Module.
Keine Ahnung.
Chrome suspended die Tabs. Ja, ich glaube auch.
Ich glaube auch,
dass Chrome die Tabs suspended.
Weil ansonsten
hätte ich nicht
nur 22G RAM
gejuiced
von 64.
A Boomer Vibe.
Das ist
eine alte IBM Werbung.
Ja, du hast nichts verpasst,
außer unser Daily Scrum heute.
Wir machen heute nichts Spannendes.
Ich bin einfach mal online gekommen für 2 Stunden
abends noch, um ein bisschen
Laberstells zu machen. Und nachdem jemand
gesagt hat, Max, die besten Streams von dir sind die
Laberstreams, was ich persönlich
nicht so sehen würde. Ich finde eigentlich, die Streams
von Chrome was machen, deutlich
besser, auch im Nachhinein. Ich gucke mir sogar
Streams von mir manchmal im Nachhinein an,
noch so nebenbei.
Beispielsweise die letzten Bastel-Streams
und sowas. Aber es kann jedem gefallen,
was er will. Trotzdem, schön, dass du deinen Weg
hergefunden hast, Drachenflieger.
Fog.
Was haben wir denn hier? Was haben wir eigentlich
hier noch alles offen?
Google erfindet Softwareentwicklung neu.
Mag ich heute einmal zu gucken.
Das neue Video
von Jules wollen wir auch gucken.
Den Rest könnte ich eigentlich längst
wieder zumachen. Das ist alles schon outdated,
overrated, debated.
Haben wir entweder schon geguckt
oder ist nicht mehr aktuell.
Ne.
Ich kann den Talk nicht anfangen. Ich bin bloß noch 10 Minuten online.
Waren es nicht auch 10 Minuten,
wo man vom Münchner Hauptbahnhof zum
Flughafen
braucht?
Ich glaube, das waren 10 Minuten.
Also ich brauche zum Frankfurter Flughafen
einen Verlänger.
In welcher Welt?
Wie hieß der Kerl damals?
Der bayerische...
Was war denn der damals? Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Der Stoiber.
Genau. Der hat noch irgendeine Rede gehalten.
10 Minuten vom
neuen Hauptbahnhof zum Flughafen
oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich noch weiß von dem Typ.
10 Minuten.
Und in London,
wenn sie nach London fahren,
dann in 10 Minuten.
Das war ganz furchtbar weird.
Und der hat die Sätze
immer nicht rausbekommen.
Der hat immer gesagt,
noch mehr
Boomer Vibes.
Giga Games Intro.
Das ist wirklich richtig
Boomer Vibes.
Zu den Zeiten, wo ich die Rocket Beans echt noch gerne
geguckt habe. Damals waren es ja noch nicht
die Rocket Beans, aber es waren
einige davon. Ich weiß nicht, guckt
noch einer Rocket Beans von euch?
Ich muss sagen, ich habe nie
viel geguckt,
aber die ein oder anderen Sachen habe ich geguckt,
aber ich gucke schon Jahre nicht mehr.
Interessiert mich einfach nicht.
Der größte Teil
davon.
Game One war nice.
Okay.
Chat, hätte ich mal ein bisschen runtergescrollt
auf YouTube, hätte ich euch vorhin gar nicht fragen müssen.
Hier steht es ja auch.
Es war ein Wildschwein.
Irgendwie nicht so wirklich spannendes
Zeug, was YouTube heute am Start hat, oder?
Der Wolfgang hat
ein neues Video.
Der war sogar witzigerweise mal hier
im Stream, als wir ein Video von ihm geguckt haben.
Vor ein paar Monaten.
Was ist denn das? Das haben wir uns glaube ich schon
angeguckt, ne?
Ein Tag in Wiesbaden. Oh ja, wenn ich
einschlafen will, gucke ich mir das jetzt an.
Obwohl, ich will einschlafen.
Post Champ.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an.
Wir gucken uns das kein Tag in Wiesbaden an.
Leute, wisst ihr, woran ich merke, dass ich
richtig krasser Boomer geworden bin?
Also nicht nur am Alter, wenn ich da jetzt überlege.
Sondern auch, was ich teilweise
für Sachen mir angucke.
Manchmal, wenn ich nicht pennen kann,
dann gucke ich mir dann so Sachen an,
wie Hessens schönste Wanderwege und sowas.
Das ist
mega entspannend.
Hessens schönste Wanderwege oder
Hessens schönste Schiffsstrecken
oder
so Dinger.
Das geht dann meistens so eine halbe Stunde,
45 Minuten.
Da laufen die dann ein bisschen rum und zeigen
und schwätzen nicht so viel.
Da penne ich immer ein bei.
Ich kriege da meistens so 5 Minuten von mit.
Nee, Fernsehgarten gucke ich nicht.
So ein Schrott.
Wahlgesänge.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt mal
kurz was zu sagen.
Ich
vielleicht geht es ja noch ein paar andere Leute so.
Also vor ein paar Jahren,
das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ich würde mal sagen,
bestimmt schon seit ich hier im Haus wohne.
10 Jahre.
10 Jahre plus ist das so.
Und wahrscheinlich
ist es auch meine eigene Schuld.
Aber, ich kann
nicht mehr richtig pennen,
ohne, dass ich irgendwas
im Hintergrund laufen habe.
Sei es jetzt irgendein YouTube Video.
Also ich habe schon eine komplette Playlist
für Sachen, die ich anhören kann,
wenn ich am Pennen bin.
Und Sachen, die ich mir an...
Ich kann nicht mehr richtig einschlafen
und pennen, wenn nichts läuft.
Das ist total merkwürdig.
Früher ging es mir auf den Sack,
wenn irgendwo was lief.
Da musste ich es einfach still haben, dass ich pennen konnte.
Ich kann nicht mehr pennen.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich selbst darauf
konditioniert, irgendwie mit zu viel Handy
im Bett noch irgendwie Streams geguckt
und sowas.
Und
seit Jahren ist es schon so,
dass ich nicht mehr pennen kann.
Und ich habe eine extra Playlist
für Dinge, die
ich mir...
Es müssen Sachen sein,
die mich vom Inhalt her
nicht
beschäftigen.
Das ist wichtig.
Also ich kann mir Hessens schönste Wanderwege
angucken oder...
Lass dir die Geschichte gucken.
Dungeons & Dragons Lore-Videos
gucke ich mir beispielsweise.
Also angucken ist zu viel gesagt.
Die höre ich mir an. Da gibt es Leute,
die erzählen dann eineinhalb Stunden über irgendwelche...
Was weiß ich?
Die
stärksten Dungeons & Dragons
Artefakte und sowas. Eineinhalb Stunden.
Das finde ich...
Ich mag so Lore-Videos,
aber es ist nicht so, dass es mich beschäftigt.
Da ratze ich immer direkt weg bei.
Ich gucke
jetzt gerade mal hier.
Leute,
ich habe keine Ahnung. Wisst ihr...
Hört mal kurz.
Wisst ihr, was das letzte Video ist
in meiner Watch-History?
Total wirr. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Aber ungelogen. Das letzte Video
in meiner Watch-History. Passt mal auf.
Ihr werdet es
erkennen. Achtung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das letzte Video in meiner Watch-History
ist Elricita's Love.
Elricita's Laughing.
Keine Ahnung,
warum ich das als letztes Video in der History
habe. Ich bin mir gar nicht bewusst
gewesen, dass ich das heute im Laufe des Tages
angeklickt habe.
Keine Ahnung, warum das da drin ist.
Ja. So. Und ich habe extra so
eine Späte... Und was ich mir auch super
angucken, anhören kann...
Anhören ist ja das beste...
Umschreibung für nicht angucken. Es sind zwar Videos,
aber ich höre mir die mal an. Das sind irgendwelche
Science-Videos. So...
Neues schwarzes Loch
in 15 Milliarden
Lichtjahren Entfernung entdeckt und so was.
Wo dann einer eineinhalb Stunden
darüber erzählt und solche Dinge.
Gucke ich übelst gerne.
Finde ich vom Thema auch ganz interessant.
Würde ich mir wahrscheinlich sogar angucken.
Auch ohne, dass ich pennen
will. Aber ich kann dabei trotzdem gut pennen.
Wenn ihr versteht.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Möglich wäre es. Ich weiß
nicht, was das weit entferntesten Objekte
mittlerweile sind.
Wie alt ist das Universum? 13,7 Milliarden
Jahre oder irgendwie sowas?
Ah.
Universe Age.
Ah. Oh. Immerhin.
Bin ich gar nicht so schlecht
mit 13,7 Milliarden Jahren.
White Noise? Ne, das mag ich nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt. Ich habe extra
Playlist dafür.
Und ich kann
mittlerweile nicht mehr pennen.
Ja, so rund 14 Milliarden.
Ja.
13,7, 13,8,
14 kann man sich merken.
Ist Brown Noise
das, was von Lampen kommt?
Oder das vom Heizlüfter?
Ne, vom Heizlüfter ist eher White Noise, oder?
Aber ich
habe schon überlegt, ob es nicht sinnvoll wäre
mal wieder
einfach zu versuchen
mal ein paar Wochen lang
zu pennen
ohne
Hintergrund.
Also ohne YouTube im Hintergrund.
Weil
ich gehe davon aus, dass man besser schläft,
wenn man keine YouTube Videos im Hintergrund
laufen hat.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass man dann
besser schläft.
Aber ich kann halt nicht richtig pennen irgendwie,
wenn nichts im Hintergrund läuft. Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Und ich habe auch schon gemerkt,
wenn die Videos dann ausgehen,
weil irgendwie die Playlist zu Ende ist
oder sowas,
dann träume ich teilweise ganz, ganz
merkwürdiges Zeug
und
wenn ich irgendwie dann aufwache und ich
wieder ein Video anmache,
oder sei es nur ein bisschen
Hintergrundmusik oder so, dann kann ich wieder
ganz normal pennen. Sehr merkwürdig.
Also nur mal so als Beispiel,
was ich für komische Dinger träume
teilweise, wenn ich im Hintergrund
nichts laufen habe. Ich habe letztens geträumt,
dass meine Katze
aufgeblasen werden konnte wie ein Luftballon.
Also ich
habe die nicht aufgeblasen, die hat sich selbst
aufgeblasen wie ein Luftballon.
Ich weiß noch, ich habe meine Katze
angeguckt und die hat sich dann selbst
aufgeblasen wie ein Luftballon.
Mehr war da nicht.
Dann hat es zum nächsten gewechselt, ja?
Ja!
Ich lasse sie weiterlaufen,
während ich penne. Ich kann nicht
gut schlafen, wenn keine
Videos im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich gucke mir ja auch nur Sachen an,
die nicht laute Geräusche enthalten,
oder irgendwie aufreibende Sachen
beinhalten.
Ich gucke mir Dungeons & Dragons Lore Videos,
World of Warcraft Lore Videos an,
Warhammer Lore Videos an,
oder irgendwelche
Universum neue Entdeckungen
und
ich habe den Vorteil, bei mir geht die
Playlist nicht aus, weil
ich habe doch YouTube Premium
und mit YouTube Premium kann
man sich eine temporäre Playlist
erstellen und ich klicke mir meistens
abends, wenn ich im Bett liege
aus
zwei, drei anderen Playlists oder
Sachen, was meine Startseite
empfiehlt, klicke ich mir einfach
fünf, sechs Videos
zusammen und lasse sie dann laufen.
Ich kenne ja schon
die Channels, die nicht rumschreien.
Brauchst immer einen Ventilator, der rauscht.
Also im Rechenzentrum müde
geworden bin ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie.
Da ist einfach zu laut,
es zieht zu sehr und es ist je nachdem, wie
es eingestellt ist, auch zu kalt.
Mittlerweile geht der Trend in Rechenzentren
ja hin, dass man es eher ein bisschen wärmer hat.
Einfach, weil es extrem viel Geld spart.
Felix, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Extremly Pog
Subscription. Max, ich
habe seit heute meinen ersten 3D Drucker.
Was hast du dir für einen gekauft?
Also ich benutze den regelmäßig,
aber sehr selten.
Ich druck mir meistens
irgendwelche Cases aus für
Microcontroller
Projekte oder irgendwelche kleinen
Sachen.
Das letzte, was ich ausgedruckt habe, ist
sowas, was man Wasserhahn dran machen kann.
Aber ich benutze es nicht oft.
Also
nur mal so, dass ihr wisst, wie selten
ich das benutze. Bei meinem 3D Drucker
war eine Rolle weißes Filament dabei.
Also eine komplette Rolle weißes Filament
und da ist immer noch ein bisschen was übrig.
Obwohl ich den jetzt bestimmt
auch schon 3 Jahre oder so habe.
Apropos Domains, kann Cloudflare
endlich Dev?
Das interessiert mich nicht. Was mich interessiert ist,
ob Cloudflare jemals DE kann.
Cloudflare kann kein DE.
Ist es möglich, dass ich wieder DNS-Rechte
für Wobblers teile?
Ja, wenn
man das scheren kann.
Accountmäßig,
klar.
Schreibt mir mal im Discord,
dass ich es morgen sehe. Dann können wir das einstellen.
Ja, Rechenzentrum mit
Kopfhörern ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Meinst du richtig echte Kopfhörer mit Musik
oder meinst du diese Mäuse?
Wie heißen die
Mäuse eigentlich richtig? Gehörschutz
wahrscheinlich, oder?
Einfach nur Gehörschutz.
Ja, aber das sagt, dass
Cloudflare keine DE-Domains kann.
Dann würde ich einfach alles zu Cloudflare
umziehen und hätte meine Ruhe.
Ein gebrauchten Ender-3?
Okay.
Das war ja damals auch schon ein Einsteigergerät.
Aber wenn man nicht viel druckt, denke ich, ganz okay.
Wobei halt
höherpreisige so coole Features haben.
Aber gut, dass du schon so
einen Leveling-Sensor hast.
Oh, es ist 22 Uhr.
Was ist jetzt?
Ihr wisst es genau, Chat.
Jetzt ist
richtig Bett-Getime.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen
ist jetzt angesagt.
Mir ist das nicht egal, dass die keine DE-Domains
haben. Ich hab nämlich DE-Domains.
Du brauchst Cloudflare
wegen CNAME
Flattening.
Was ist
CNAME Flattening?
Hä? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich bin zu low IQ heute Abend.
Ich hab nicht genug Subs.
Nee, ich bin einfach müde jetzt.
Hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Ist fürs Wochenende was geplant?
Du meinst, ob ich was
geplant hab oder ob streammäßig
was geplant ist?
Streammäßig ist was geplant, ja.
Sind sogar
zwei Sachen geplant streammäßig.
Streammäßig ist zum ersten
geplant.
Die Sachen mit den
also die Sachen, die ich
beim Prime Day bestellt habe
heimautomatisierungstechnisch
auszuprobieren. Da sind ja neue
Sensoren dabei. Ich hab einen neuen
Zigbee-Stick bestellt.
Und ein paar Sachen, wo ich ausprobieren will, ob die
überhaupt laufen über Zigbee.
Da müssen wir uns
am besten den Home Assistant auf den Raspberry Pi
klatschen, um den neuen Zigbee-Stick
wobei das ja kein reiner Zigbee-Stick ist.
Das ist ja ein Zigbee bzw. Thread
Stick. Der ist sogar zukunftssicher.
Ausprobieren.
Und dann machen wir wieder mal
eine Runde Broggers. Also wir machen Basteln
und Broggers. Ich kann euch aber nicht versprechen,
dass ich beides hinkriege am Wochenende.
Ja, ich hab auch ein Mega
i3 Mega
S, aber
ohne dieses automatische
Leveling-Zeug.
Nachdem ich sehr selten Sachen spiele
unregelmäßig, aber
wenn mal
wieder Battlefield oder
Battlebit oder sowas auf dem Programm steht
da machen wir manchmal
zwar Matchmaking, aber Leute aus dem Chat
können joinen, ja.
Aber ich lade am liebsten Leute ein, von denen ich weiß,
dass sie gut spielen.
Ich reg mich schon in den Games
genug auf, dann brauche ich auf jeden Fall ein paar
gescheite Teammates.
Aber ihr seid natürlich immer eingeladen,
ins Gegner-Team zu gehen und zu spenden.
Da habe ich keine Schmerzen mit.
Aha.
Sonntag ist immer
Stream.
Sonntag ist immer Aufwachen-Stream.
Vielleicht aber nachmittags auch noch Bastel-Kram
oder Samstag halt.
Ja, mache ich jetzt auch. Ich gehe jetzt
pennen. Leute, bis dann. Wir sehen uns.
See you.